(Whoosh)
- I want it to be
documented the first time
I ever pull a card of me in it.
This is super insane.
Oh, I got one!
- [Crew] (laughing)
Yeah, let's go!
I got it!
I fucking got it!
Let's go!
(fists pounding table)
That was amazing.
(upbeat music)
So many people are asking me how,
how do I live my dream, Gary?
And, you know, I don't have time.
I have mortgages and bills and
responsibilities and my job.
I don't have time for my side hustle,
my Twitch channel, my Instagram account,
my Shopify store selling hoodies.
And I keep getting to this new place,
which is talk to me about your bills.
Why'd you buy an apartment
that stretches you?
Why is your car so fancy?
Why do you need the new Gucci every time?
Why are you going out Thursday,
Friday and Saturday night?
Why are you going to Coachella?
Why are you going to
Avengers opening night
and buying the biggest
piece of popcorn and candy?
The answer to all of your questions
is not how much money you make
or how much time you have.
It's what you're spending your money on.
(upbeat music)
- I love your slime video.
It was amazing.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- And I thought
it was really exciting
Because it showed that you
don't need to think about
what other people think
of you or anything.
If somebody says that
you're dumb, you say, okay.
♪ Okay. ♪
(audience laughs)
(Gary applauds)
(audience applauds)
- Come up here.
Come up here.
(audience applauds)
You're the smartest girl here.
Give me a hug.
Thank you.
(audience cheers)
If she knows, what's your fucking problem?
♪ You ain't gotta do it like me ♪
♪ Please don't be stupid like me, me ♪
- Ready?
I'm tired of talking about
people having the ability
to tune out the negative.
I'm done telling you to
not worry about haters
and trolls and negative opinions.
I'm actually flipping
the fucking script on you
and I'm gonna yell at
and I'm gonna push at
and I'm just gonna try to inspire
or communicate a perspective
for you to stop hearing the cheering.
The reason so many
struggle with negativity
is because they over value
positive reinforcement.
You're addicted to people
telling you you're pretty.
You're addicted to people telling you
you're good at basketball.
You're addicted to parents
and teachers telling you
you're a good student.
You're addicted to opinions.
Once you learn how to
not over value somebody
who's commending or complimenting you,
is the second you go down the path
of dealing with the reverse.
(intense music)
What people don't understand
is how much work I put
to even begin the process
of being who I am today.
2007, 2011's a long time
ago for a lot of people.
That year, I decided
to go on Twitter search
and anybody that talked about wine,
I jumped in and talked to them.
How did I get here?
Hand to hand combat.
Give me your phone.
Let me show you something.
- [Man] Oh, here you go.
- So, you go to Columbia,
Maryland; you go to places.
Right?
So, I'm in the search, right?
This is gonna work for all
of you if you wanna build.
So, you just go to Columbia, Maryland
and right now it's gonna show you
all the top photos and
all the recent photos.
What I did, but on Twitter,
with the word Pinot Noir,
is I literally, look,
Instagram's a little bit
of a different, the first
photo is like a dude
who's looking real
fucking diesel and shit.
And so like--
(group laughs)
I mean, you could, you could...
I'm not joking. I would
literally go in here and be
like swole, post.
- Right, right.
I did it.
(group laughs)
- [Woman] He's like, I'm worth it man.
- [Phone Owner] I don't care,
let me see my phone man.
- But this is, look, there's
a couple good things going
for you.
One, your name is a (mumbles),
the fact, this is how I think, right?
I think--
- I was gonna ask you
about that too.
- Right?
(muffled speaking)
- I think, it is good.
And again, look, what's
gonna be unpopular,
attractive people.
So as a guy, it's a pretty girl,
you don't wanna come across creepy.
You gotta be thoughtful.
- Yeah.
- You don't have to go to every post.
But, you go to these posts, right?
And this is happening in,
these posts are happening in,
this town, right?
For example, here's something
about when went to--
- Wegmans.
- Wegmans, right?
Literally, your like, love that.
And I'm doing it right for you right now,
because I don't think people get it.
Love that place, right?
So, I want you to become
the mayor of the town.
I did what I just showed
you for four hours,
five hours, six hours a day on Twitter.
If I was nobody, which
is 99% of people now,
I don't have a million followers.
I'm trying to grow.
I'm trying to build my
dreams and aspirations.
I'm literally doing what I just showed you
for ten hours a day.
(upbeat music)
- Yeah, I know it's possible
- Of course it's possible,
millions of people do it.
The question is, are you
hungry enough and willing
to fucking eat shit or are you soft?
- I believe I'm willing to do it 'cause,
I know following you, I hear
that, you know, eat shit.
I feel like people that
unless maybe they got a stroke
of just complete luck, you
know that's what they've,
they at least had to eat
shit a little bit, you know?
- Everybody ate--
my man, every single person
that's made it, they made it,
they ate shit and did the work.
There's people that inherited money.
There's people that have won the lottery.
Let's stop thinking about those people.
Everybody spends all their time
thinking about those people.
Those people are enigmas.
They're anomalies.
They're the .00001%.
They have nothing to do with you.
- Yeah.
- The 99.999,
that made something of
themselves, ate shit.
They put in the work.
- You're right.
- I know I'm right.
Everybody's fixated on
fucking 4,000 people,
while there's 7.7 billion
people who fucking worked
or didn't and then failed.
You wanna be an actor, get
your ass to fucking L.A.
- Yeah.
- What do you mean how to
start? You don't know anybody?
Fucking, of course you know somebody.
Tweet on Instagram right
now, be like, who's in L.A.?
You know who's in L.A.,
your former teammate's fucking sister.
Your fucking friend from
high school's uncle.
People are in L.A.
You know fucking 30 people in L.A.
You haven't fucking asked.
- Yeah.
- I know.
- Yeah, I mean, that's,
yeah, you're right dude.
- I know I'm right dude.
And I want it for you.
- No, I appreciate that--
- And the best part is
you might suck shit at acting
but you need to find that out.
- Yeah.
- Get your fucking North
Carolina ass to L.A.
- No, I will--
- Take Ashley with you
and fucking go!
Live your fucking life.
Don't fucking buy into
an antiquated process.
You can act tomorrow.
(upbeat music)
Couple things, you've made enough contact
with not enough use,
where my normal talk of,
you're being impatient,
goes out the window.
- Yeah.
- You are definitely,
at this point, not making content
that's connecting and that doesn't,
and listen to me, listen to me.
That doesn't need to be
devastating like, oh fuck,
- Yeah.
- nobody likes me, or I suck.
That needs to be, how do
I make different content?
Maybe you need to do a talk show format.
Maybe you need to--
- Well, yeah I have a budget
(faintly speaking)
- You understand?
Don't dwell that that's happening,
but you definitely need
to mix something up
with your content.
You gotta try different shit.
- Yeah.
- Because you've done enough,
your telling me that
you've done 300 videos
and they still only get 20 or 30 views?
- Well some of them have 1,000 but--
- But for the most part,
- Yeah (faintly speaking)
- It's really tough to
give this advice because,
it almost comes across as
hurting one's feelings.
- No that's what I'm --
- But, on the flip,
I'm actually excited about it.
You are very rare.
You've gone hard enough, long
enough around a certain way
that you've given me the
opportunity to give rare advice,
which is, hey, you can't
do that shit no more.
(faintly speaking)
You have to completely switch it out.
That has been proven to
me, with those numbers,
as it does not work.
- Okay, do you think I
should do a new YouTube,
a new everything or?
- I don't think you have to, you can.
First of all, it's great that
you have that, when you're 59,
when your 95, your gonna
love seeing 16 year old you.
- Yeah. I love seeing 12
year old me right now.
- Right?
It's cool.
No, I don't think you have to.
I think you just need
to come out and be like,
I went to ComplexCon.
I saw GaryVee.
This is the video. He
told me to switch it out.
My next video's gonna be switching it out
and that video becomes the one
that starts the new chapter.
- Now hopefully my boss isn't watching,
I told him I'm doing--
- The In and Out boss?
- Yeah.
- Yo, fuck the In and Out boss!
- No, yeah, I kinda got mad
at him because he was mad
that I wanted to call off today so.
Sorry Drew!
(laughing)
- You could go work in
Jack In The Box, fuck that.
I'm not worried about that.
- I'm this close to quitting.
I am over it.
- Yeah, we're not worried
about the In and Out
fucking burger manager.
- Oh!
- Drew!
- Drew.
- Fuck you Drew.
So, that we're not worried about.
What I'm worried about is you saying hey,
what I wanted to do doesn't work.
- Yeah.
- And as much as that hurts,
and it hurts.
- It does, it does.
- It hurts.
- But yeah.
- As much as that hurts,
I'm gonna flip it up.
(upbeat music)
I'm being serious.
You're literally gonna
live four more lives,
five more, like from the day you were born
that you cannot fucking
remember to right this second,
you're about to do that
three to four more times.
You can sit literally,
literally, your biggest advantage
is timing.
For all the great things
that I have in my life,
I would literally give it
up, all of it, all of it,
just to be 25.
I would give up, for 17
years, I'd give up everything
I have, cause that's how valuable time is.
And the far majority
of this room has time,
time as their asset and every
day the number one asset
they have, time, they give
away by being impatient mainly
on the back of listening
to society or their parents
that they have to have their
shit figured out at this age.
The fact that people actually
think, at 18, 22 or 30,
you have to have your shit figured out,
is fucking ridiculous.
Let me promise you, all
those parents and uncles
and grandparents that
push down your throat,
that you have to figure it out by now,
they still haven't
figured it the fuck out.
- [Audience] (cheering)
- I mean it.
So, this nonsense, this
fucking nonsense that you have
to have it figured out at 18, 22, 30.
You know how many people
freak the fuck out at 30?
How many people are 30 right now?
That shit was crazy right?
People lose their shit at 30.
Meanwhile they're a fucking kid.
And so, I'm unbelievably
aware lately that one of the,
you know, people are
just like why do you win?
Talk about my parents and
not coming from anything.
But the more that I live, I'm like shit,
the reason I really win,
is cause I understand time.
And listen, I know I can get hit by a bus
or get terminally ill.
I get it.
Here's the problem.
That's far more unlikely
for the majority of us.
The math works in your favor
and we are stunningly not patient.
(upbeat music)
- It's funny how that
just went through my mind.
I actually think being lazy,
is a good thing.
Let me explain.
This is gonna be an interesting moment.
Yeah, no, your freaking out right?
- Well, I was gonna say,
isn't stop watching Netflix
kinda related to laziness?
- Stop watching Netflix
is under the context
stop using something to
escape your real life.
If you don't realize your
trying to escape your real life.
Don't use Netflix or watching the New--
Let's get very much into
clarification on this episode.
I watch the Jets for
four hours on Sundays.
I do that because it allows me to escape
and it gives me balance to my insanity,
but I don't watch the Jets
on Sunday to get away from
the fact that I hate my job and instead
of doing something for my
job, I'm gonna use this
because Netflix is a
seven day a week thing.
2K and Fortnite is a
And even sports, people
that watch the Yankees
and the Mets and the Knicks and the Jets,
the way I watch the Jets, that's
why football worked for me.
One day a week, you know.
Some people use entertainment
as a reset and a balance
to their other life,
which is work, family.
- Mm Hmm.
- And then other people
use escapism as a way
to just get by because
they hate their life
and it's the way for them not
to have to think about it.
Right?
Laziness has my attention
because I think, if you're lazy,
your actually giving yourself a indication
that you don't like it.
So, I think laziness is --
- That you don't like what?
- Whatever the task at hand.
For you, you just prob--
You'll appreciate this
and I think you can see it
in trash talk.
I mean I'm never...
D. Rock will tell you, who
hangs out with me a lot.
That between trash talk
and the baseball cards show
in Chicago, he's never seen me happier.
I get an incredible thrill,
deep, inherent happiness
from getting into a car on a
6AM on a Saturday and going
to find something to buy for three bucks
and sell for a hundred.
This is not about the
cliche shit that people say
in my comments like, you
didn't make that much money,
it was the ga--
- You know.
- Yeah.
- It's not all those things.
I love it.
School I hated.
I am lazy around housework,
around logistics.
I think quote on quote laziness
can have a more thoughtful conversation
of actually is it laziness
or are you showing yourself
that you don't like that thing
and it becomes a mechanism
to self awareness--
- I think it's that.
- Me too!
- I think it's that you don't,
they--
(upbeat music)
- The most important thing I think about
when I think about getting to happiness
is not so much owning anything.
It's the ability to not
hear anything but yourself.
There's nothing more powerful than
when everything gets
quiet and the only thing
that penetrates is your own voice
and that voice isn't judging you.
- [Director] When you look back, now,
at the kid who felt pressure
or the kid who felt an obligation.
What would you say to that kid now?
- I would tell that kid to stay the course
cause he's gotta figure it out.
(thundering music)
- Topps, series two, released
today and in the packs
of Topps Series Two, it's the first time
I'm ever gonna see it.
In the back in small...
I mean Jesus Christ, this is small print.
I'm getting old.
But, in the packs of Topps
Series Two is an insert card
called GaryVee's top
entrepreneur's in baseball.
Where there, is it a 12 card set?
(faintly speaking)
We picked 12 guys
and then there's, so there's 12 cards,
different players, 12 different players.
You get one of those in every 18 pack.
So, almost one or two in a box, I think.
- Yeah, it should have--
- But that's going off
the top of my head.
And then there's the dual
auto card, where you can get
an autograph of me and the player.
There's a, in one of
these packs, for example,
I can pull right now
- That's one of 5,000 packs.
- I know it's one of 5,000
packs, dual autos right?
- Yeah.
- I'm gonna try to pull a card of my--
I want it to be documented, the first time
I ever pull a card of me in it.
This is super insane.
Oh, I got one!
Yeah, let's go!
- [Crew] (laughing)
- I got it!
I fucking got it!
Let's go!
(laughing)
(hands drumming on the table)
That was amazing!
There it is!
Jose Ramirez, GaryVee's Topp ah--
I cannot believe I just pulled
it out. It was so awesome!
How insane is this!
I am literally on a fucking baseball card.
Are you fucking kidding me?
(laughing)
This is insane.
That was so fucking cool!
(upbeat music)
- So, my question, my
dream, my ultimate dream,
is to be on Team GaryVee doing
community management and--
- You wanna move to New York?
- Yeah.
- Let's do it.
- [Audience] (cheering)
(upbeat music)
- I'm Oprah in this bitch.
- [Audience] (cheering)
- Ring the fucking bell.
Ring the fucking bell.
(bell ringing)
- [Audience] (cheering)
(upbeat music)
(inspirational music)
- I always play this out.
Let's say, when you go to heaven,
they can show you what could have happened
cause that's the only
way you'd ever see it.
Let's just say.
What people don't understand is, oh,
you made the wrong call, you shoulda went
to grad school instead of that opportunity
with this company instead of that company.
But, you'll never believe it.
You should've went to Vayner
Media and it was perfect
and you rose like a phoenix
and you were the head
of all sound and everything went great.
But then you had to go
to Virginia on business
and you got hit by a
car and you died at 31.
(peaceful music)
That's life.
I passed on Uber as an investor
twice in the beginning.
If I did my normal 25, $50,000 check,
I would have made $400 million.
Which means, I might have went to China
for a keynote two years ago,
which means I coulda got hit
by a fucking bus.
I really believe in that shit.
You just don't know.
You think you know, but
that is not how life works.
So, to look at two ideas and
think you can practically
make a good decision is laughable.
Literally flip a coin.
(coin dropping)
Just pick the one that feels
better right that second
and make it about you.
Because usually what kids
struggle with is the decision
they want to do versus the decision
that they think they're
supposed to do based
on the other voices.
(upbeat music)
Think about this.
If you grew up loving
and flipping sneakers
and one day you had your
own signature sneaker,
that's what theses cards are for me.
This has literally been
the best week of my life.
- Really?
- Yeah, man.
This is just like, I'm literally sad
that's it's Saturday night.
I don't do five days of anything.
D Rock will tell you, I fly
to give a speech in Hawaii
and fly back, I'm there for four minutes.
I never stay anywhere ever.
I wish I could live
here for the next year.
- Wow.
- This is as good as it gets.
(laughing)
It's fucking Wednesday.
This is worth 100 cases of cash.
- Yes.
(muffled speaking)
- A lot going on.
- I love you.
(peaceful music)